punishing new American sanctions against
Iran will move into place in less than a
week Elizabeth Palmer is in Tehran and
she sat down with iran's Foreign
Minister Mohammad Javad Zarif they
talked about anti-government protests by
Iranians frustrated with the country's
struggling economy and the sanctions but
you're about to suffer a new round of
sanctions that you yourse I say are
going to hurt is that going to make the
protests worse as I said I everybody
believes that the impact of those
sanctions have already affected your
hoping that anyway because you have no
idea how much your revenue may decrease
next year if the Americans really play
hardball and convince the Chinese in the
Indians not to buy your oil you had a
big problem on your hands well I think
the Americans will have a bigger problem
in their hand if that were to take place
why because because then we will take
our own measures in response like like
what we decide to take as president
Trump said I want to keep him guessing
there will be more of Elizabeth's
interview with iran's Foreign Minister
on our streaming network cbsn